We're talking DIY all week long,
and next we get to get our hands dirty
and take the DIY sneaker trend that is blowing up TikTok.
People are taking a pair of $15 sneakers
from Walmart right here,
and transforming 'em into painted works of art.
They're called Walmart's Time and Tru Platform Sneakers.
Check these out.
Look at that, and look,
that's what people are doing to them.
How creative people are?
And here to show us how it's done,
we have an incredible artist and designer known
for her custom shoes of all kind.
Please welcome, Jordana Schrager.
(audience cheering)
Hi Jordana.
Hello, it's great to be here.
Okay Jordana, I just want you to know
that I am fully fan girling out on you.
You have really got it going on.
I mean, you've designed for Miley, Selena Gomez.
You've done amazing collaborations with Uggs, Converse,
Maybelline.
Oh my goodness.
Like how did you get into this?
Why are you so amazing?
I wanna work with you.
(Ross laughing)
So I actually started customizing sneakers when I was
in high school,
and it was really just like a fun hobby at the time.
And now I've been doing it for over 12 years,
which is so crazy.
And I love using sneakers as my canvas.
I feel like there's just so much to do to them,
and you could have so much fun with it.
Will you teach us how to do this, please?
Yeah, I want to get dirty in these paints Jordana.
Oh sure.
First thing you're gonna need is white shoes.
And then you're going to need some colored paints.
So these paints are leather paints.
They're great for sneakers
and you can wear the shoes afterwards all day long,
and just pick your favorite color.
And I'm gonna section off the shoes.
So I like to start in the back,
and you can see that there's a nice section for the paint.
So we're gonna go in with this paint and you can do it
in any direction you want.
And I would just make sure to take it slow,
and try to stay within the lines if possible.
Take it slow Jordana,
I'm a jack rabbit.
You are.
I don't know how
to take anything slow.
Jordana who is like your dream person to call you
for a collab?
I work on a Nike's all the time,
so I think that would be really fun.
I mean, honestly,
there's so many companies that I'd love to work with,
and I think that's one of the best parts of my job
is creating like one of a kind unique designs
for a company and a collaboration.
You get to create like really fun,
colorful designs for a company like Maybelline.
And then I could do a completely different collaboration.
Just have to come up with
all new different designs for them.
Speaking of your designs,
I think I have a design right here.
Would you like to tell Drew what inspired this one?
So this sneaker was inspired by Flower by Drew
and (Jordana laughing)
I really wanted it to just be really fun and colorful,
and I of course had to add a adorable flower print
to the sneakers
Look these are, yes for you.
Wait.
I get a pair.
These are yours.
Oh my god, Jordana.
I'm so excited to have a Jordana original.
Yay.
I love you so much.
Thank you so much.
I'm gonna take a picture of myself with them.
You're showing everybody how to self create,
be affordable, express themselves,
and you're inviting everyone into the party,
and thank you for all that you're putting out
into the world.
Thank you so much.
Well we love your Jordana and this is the beginning
of a long and beautiful friendship.
(upbeat music)